fresh and crisp but is it also healthy  and all-natural more and more German  consumers are watching what they buy if  there are chemicals hormones or modified  genes in their tomatoes or sausage they  want to know it Murdo to see that on the  label I'd like to know what i'm eating  minus so much is so suspicious of  everything you need some kind of help  the customers ask about it and want to  know that everything's alright so should  non-genetically modified produce be  labeled as such yes say eighty-two  percent of Germans only sixteen percent  don't see any need for any labeling of  GM produce and something that not even a  label is enough again second labeling is  only a half measure they shouldn't even  be selling that stuff golf n your coffee  all we buy at the farmers market the  produce is locally grown and I think  we're safe there so Fargo and by the way  over three-quarters of German consumers  would pay more for products guaranteed  gm-free  you  you